foreign
Brandon is with us in Denver hey Brandon
how are you
I'm good Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up
okay so this has happened before with my
sister this is basically what it's about
so my sister I'm 27 years old and my
sister is 46 she'll be 47 in April
and she always seems to have trouble
financially
and recently she asked me for a hundred
dollars and I'm not sure if she's aware
that I know that she owes my mom 800.
and
I kind of wanted to like offer her
advice and help her out but I in my mind
I feel like she's gonna be like okay
what is this 27 year old punk trying to
school me on anything he's the one with
a hundred dollars you don't have that's
what he is
yeah I know I yeah no I get it and it's
a little frustrating because I feel like
if it was I feel like if anyone's asking
for money it should be it should be the
other way around
but you know it's like I don't know
exactly how to bring it up to her
because I don't wanna I feel like my mom
and dad always end up giving her money
and I've always told them like you know
this isn't really helping her it's more
so perpetuating her mismanagement of
money
and
I guess I just don't know how to go
about it without causing a rift between
us
so I want you to re re-approach the
situation you did not cause the rift the
rift was thrown at you
all you are doing now is responding to
the rift okay
and as simple as uh
um no I I'm not gonna loan you 100 thank
you though
anything after that is you trying to
smooth over your boundary and that's not
your responsibility
so there's a simple peaceful answer I'm
not going to judge the fact that you owe
Mom I'm not going to explain stuff to
you unless you invite me to that
conversation I'm just going to tell you
now um I'm not gonna not gonna loan you
100 bucks all right John that's not how
this ends though nope then it's like why
not exactly you're not just gonna you
know what does he say when she says well
why not
Oh you mean you can't even yeah I'm just
gonna choose not to and if you want to
go down the road of well well then what
because this is going to cause a rift
between you and me and our relationship
and I'm not going to do that
and this is you drawing a boundary that
no one's ever drawn from her you know
what that's going to feel like to her
abuse oh my goodness hatred edos you
here's the thing you can't control her
response to your boundary
you can't yeah I guess the thing is is
like I do feel kind of bad this was
about a week ago she asked me and I
didn't even respond to her because I
just got I had no other Pros I'm just
like in my mind I'm thinking are you
serious right now yeah good hey and good
for you for not lashing out for taking a
break okay that's that's wisdom yeah
you're smart and because putting the
snark on it that you that we all want to
tell her it's not gonna be helpful me
included it's not it's not helpful okay
it does not help her so the goal here is
to help her yeah okay and so John let me
ask you is there a way that you can
couch this I get that the boundary is
simple
um no I I'm not able to do that at this
time or I'm choosing not to do this or
whatever I'm not I'm not willing to do
that at this time okay why not yeah
um is it okay to then is it productive
then to say you know what I would choose
to do is if you will go through this
class Financial Peace University that
costs 100 I'll pay for it for you yeah
so so that you can learn how to handle
money so you never ask anybody for money
again because I've watched you struggle
and it breaks my heart
yes and well the thing is is I know that
she um her and her husband because she
does doordash on the side and her
husband's a bread Runner but he makes
really good money and um I know they I
think hired a financial advisor like
months ago but apparently obviously
didn't really do anything or the
financial advisor is an idiot one of the
two yeah or that financial advisors cash
flow right it has to do with other
things here's the thing when she when
she has to reduce finds herself in a
situation where she has to go to her
brother her 20-year younger brother nest
for money
she's already in a in if not already she
is in dangerously close to the
fight-or-flight place anyway she's
something has come up that has pushed
her to this area and then you say no and
every alarm she's got is going to start
ringing and so while what Dave said is
when you if you sit down have a cup of
coffee with her and say can we talk in
person yes I care about you a lot this
has come up a lot I know you've you've
been with Mom and Dad I want to see this
I want to help
hundred dollars is not going to help it
might bail you out of a thing you think
you have but in that moment usually
people can't hear me that's why I always
my I always recommend wait to be invited
in if you want my money here's what it's
going to come with you're going to sit
down you have to have a cup of coffee
with me so maybe that's the angle I'll
give you 100 bucks but you have to meet
me in person and you have to listen to
what I have to say and that may be where
you have a little bit
um that's kind of the I mean I'm
visiting back because I'm originally
from Maryland I'm not from Colorado yep
so I'm visiting home soon and that's
kind of something I'm a little nervous
about visiting because I don't know what
to see her but I think it's also kind of
a good opportunity as you're saying to
kind of sit down with her and talk to
her because
I just it's been going on I think ever
since she got married for like 18 years
this has been going on because
apparently she used to have a better
credit score than my dad so and now her
credit score is like really not good
yeah she's got bigger things going on
and maybe that's the angles you sit down
with her and say I want to take you to
breakfast or take you to lunch and then
say really worried about your life you
asking your little brother what's going
on are you okay
and when she says what do you mean I'm
fine I'm fine you say you just asked
your little brother for a hundred
dollars you're not okay and that becomes
an angle that is going to give you
permission into speaking to hers and
what's going on in her soul right
but the end of the day the end of the
story is regardless of her reaction or
her choice
to respond in any of these conversations
under no circumstances do you give her a
hundred dollars
except in the event that she is going to
plug into things that cause her to start
winning with money so that she never has
to ask for it again
yeah that's kind of my angle that's been
my angle for a while because I even get
upset with my parents because she's
asked me for money before and I only
gave her money one time she's probably
asking him for money like five times
um and I said no all the other four
times uh the very first time I said yes
all the other times I said no she even
asked me if I could co-sign for her
daughter for a car and I said absolutely
not good for you know all about that so
this is this is long term it's been
going on for a while so I think this
fifth time she's asked you and it's a
small and you know I think the other
thing you do do a John deloney and say
this by the way is the last time we're
going to have this discussion right this
is it because the next time you call me
for money I'm just going to tell you no
and you're going to know what I meant
when I said no yeah because I don't need
to cover this machine
yeah well she knew because even because
she texted me she didn't really even
call me which I sound weird but she
texted me and she was like I know you
don't like giving me money it's like
well yeah you know I don't it's not even
like but it's not you though it's like I
just don't like giving people money
like money that I've worked for I mean
if I I'm all about giving people gifts
and maybe like charity and volunteer and
stuff like that but
it's like repetitive and my parents I
get kind of like I don't I know I can't
do much about them but when they keep
giving their Harmony I always tell them
like please don't do that because it's
like
it's like you're they're digging the
hole well you're giving a drunk a drink
they're digging the halls of themselves
to give to put somebody out of water and
it's just like but here's the deal you
said it and I want to reiterate it you
can't do anything about what they're
doing
and so you you spoke in your piece to
your parents
I would get out of their head I'd get
out of their decision-making process and
don't don't let them have don't let this
issue have any more real estate in your
brain it's a real simple thing I'm
willing to help my sister when I in a
way that I am really helping her not in
a way that I am giving a drunk a drink
it's very simple and if she does not
want to participate in that then I'm
unwilling to have any more conversations
even about this until she is okay and I
know I'm your little brother I know this
is weird this is where we are yeah I
mean if I know it feels weird because
you're old enough to be my mother you
know I mean if you're 20 years his
senior and so uh that is very weird it's
not a classic sibling relationship
um and so
yeah you just say you know here's the
here's my terms
and they're all for your good yeah I
don't need the hundred dollars
I could give you a thousand dollars but
none of this is going to help you but I
want to really help you something's
clearly not okay yeah she's got bigger
problems than a hundred dollars
heartbroken a lot bigger problems and
because they're chronic they're ongoing